[Música]
crece la tensión diplomática en torno a
los juegos olímpicos de invierno 21 2022
china advirtió a quienes boicotean sus
juegos que lo pagaran este boicot
diplomático lo inició a eeuu y se han
sumado australia canadá y reino unido
francia por su parte dijo que no se
unirá pero llamó a una postura en común
de la unión europea
el magnate de la prensa en hong kong y
propietario del clausurado diario pro
democracia a paul daily hablamos de
jimmy ley fue declarado culpable de
reunión ilegal tras haber participado en
una vigilia no autorizada a otros
políticos y activistas de oposición
también fueron condenados tenemos
reportes desde beijing
y el senado de estados unidos rechazó el
mandato de vacunación obligatoria contra
el cubit 19 impulsado por el presidente
de bailén para las empresas con 100 o
más trabajadores el líder de la mayoría
demócrata en el senado chuck schumer
aseguró que los estadounidenses que se
han negado a fumar son el mayor
impedimento para poner fin a esta
pandemia
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 si revelan que
como siempre es para mí un placer
acompañarlos comenzamos con atención
política en torno a los juegos olímpicos
de invierno que se van a realizar en
beijing el año que viene el gobierno de
china amenaza con represalias
australia reino unido y canadá han
anunciado que se unen a este boicot
diplomático iniciado por eeuu por lo que
consideran violaciones de derechos
humanos perpetradas por las autoridades
chinas y entretanto los jefes de la
diplomacia de francia y el nuevo
gobierno alemán reunidos ahora en parís
coincidieron que es necesaria una
postura en común de la unión europea
frente a estos juegos veamos en
donde estamos a favor de una posición
común veremos lo que está en juego en la
próxima reunión de ministros de asuntos
exteriores pero esta cuestión debe ser
tratada como europeos
sin embargo esto no nos impide tener una
posición estricta sobre los derechos
humanos en china que expresamos en
particular cuando cuestionamos la
situación de península preguntas que aún
quedan sin responder una situación que
fue un tema candente recientemente y que
estamos siguiendo de cerca
extremo y por su parte china reaccionó
nuevamente tras este anuncio de más
países de sumarse al boicot
estadounidense según wang weaving el
portavoz de exteriores del gobierno
chino el deporte no tiene nada que ver
con la política de vídeo que quienes se
hayan sumado a lo que calificó como un
error van a tener que pagar el precio de
la línea aunque diego ya julia estados
unidos australia reino unido canadá y
algunos otros países se han negado a
honrar la tregua olímpica adoptada por
la asamblea general de la onu para los
juegos olímpicos de invierno de beijing
ellos inventaron dirigieron y
escenificaron unilateralmente esta farsa
de no enviar funcionarios a los juegos
dándole la espalda a la comunidad
olímpica
apoyado por siete y seguimos en asia a
jimmy lai magnate de la prensa en hong
kong y propietario del clausurado diario
por democracia post daily fue declarado
culpable de reunión ilegal tras haber
participado en una vigilia en auto junto
al empresario de 74 años fueron también
condenados otros políticos y activistas
de oposición nosotros previamente
hablamos con nuestro corresponsal en
beijing adrián foncillas y nos informó
al respecto veamos lo que nos dijo
es otro revés judicial para jimmy lai el
célebre magnate de la prensa hong kong
es a ha sido declarado culpable por
participar e incitar a la participación
en la vigilia del pasado año para
recordarte anam en ese acto
multitudinario con miles de velas
encendidas en el parque victoria forma
parte ya de la identidad hongkonesa por
el gobierno lo ha prohibido en las dos
últimas ediciones por las restricciones
al movimiento dictadas por el
coronavirus junto a jimmy la hayan sido
condenadas otras dos grandes figuras del
movimiento la abogada johan tum y la
periodista gwyneth y los tres son los
únicos que se habían declarado inocentes
de los cargos otros 16 activistas habían
sido condenados con anterioridad tras
haber aceptado los hechos la ley de
seguridad nacional cocinada por pekín y
enviada a hong kong ase un desastre para
el movimiento antigubernamental y en
especial para jimmy lai la presión
judicial de obligó a cerrar el apple
daily un diario popular que lideraba la
lucha contra pekín y en la cárcel espera
el largo listado de pleitos pendientes
esa ley divide a los con con heces para
unos
acabado con el marco de libertades para
otros en cambio devolvió la paz a la
isla después de un año de disturbios
sociales en otras noticias el senado de
eeuu aprobó por un margen estrecho una
resolución para anular la obligatoriedad
impuesta por el gobierno del presidente
joe biden para que las empresas de 100
empleados son mas vacunen a todos sus
trabajadores contra el coronavirus en su
defecto realizan pruebas diagnósticas
semanales la votación fue de 52 48 y es
poco probable que la cámara de
representantes- bajo el control
demócrata reciba la iniciativa lo que
significa que el requerimiento se
mantendrá en pie aunque los tribunales
lo han suspendido temporalmente esta
votación les dio a los senadores la
oportunidad de expresar su rechazo a una
medida que aseguran ha generado temor en
sus estados y orígenes
como diablos tiene sentido en este
momento socavar una de las herramientas
más poderosas que tenemos para vacunar a
la gente y detener este virus es fibers
lengua en qué mundo esto es una buena
idea
el gobierno federal no tiene autoridad
para hacer que nadie elija entre
vacunarse o mantener su trabajo
somos los eeuu de américa
hogar de los libres tierra de los
valientes que somos un pueblo que toma
nuestras propias decisiones y vivimos en
una nación libre sois jones en late
night free nation seguimos hablando de
noticias relacionadas con la pandemia
porque en francia se toman medidas para
evitar un colapso hospitalario cuando se
acercan las fiestas navideñas y ante el
avance de la variante omicron del sars
gov 2 desde parís nuestra periodista
natalia rizzo explicó de qué se trata
así es muy buenas tardes pues las
vacunas es así no se van de vacaciones y
fue el ministro de salud o libia de esta
mañana quien explicó pues que va a
firmar un decreto para que las farmacias
puedan operar de lunes a domingo durante
los meses de diciembre y de enero las
farmacias que quieran todo esto para
seguir vacunando cada vez a más personas
aquí por ejemplo en parís además de esto
hay tres vacunas dromos que en estos
días pues están también por abrir sus
puertas ya digamos de los 19 millones de
personas que están llamadas a recibir
esta tercera dosis y hay 11 millones que
pues ya cuentan con esa dosis de
refuerzo y en medio de esto pues el
número de casos continúa aumentando aquí
en el país más de 72 mil contagios se
registraron en las últimas 24 horas y
bueno pues ya en varias regiones del
país se ha lanzar lo que se llama como
el plan blanco en los hospitales este
permite una mayor una mayor capacidad
hospitalaria pero digamos desprogramando
o digamos aplazando algunas
intervenciones quirúrgicas que no son de
urgencia
decía esta mañana que espera que este
plan seguramente pues ya se ha puesto en
marcha para todo el país dentro de las
próximas semanas
y el presidente francés emmanuel macrón
presenta hoy jueves las prioridades de
francia para la presidencia de turno de
la unión europea que asume desde el
próximo primero de enero el mandatario
toma entonces la palabra en el inicio
para delinear su plan frente al bloque
en momentos en los que son varios los
desafíos y cuyo mandato coincida con las
próximas elecciones presidenciales
francesas del mes de abril
volver a poner en pie la unión europea
es el principal reto al que se enfrenta
de manuel macro para ello el jefe de
estado que se prepara para asumir la
presidencia del bloque durante seis
meses quiere centrar su política en tres
palabras clave recuperación poder y
pertenencia
hay que decir que no faltan proyectos el
primero de ellos es sin duda la pandemia
de kobe 19 que ha provocado una crisis
sanitaria y económica sin precedentes la
cuestión de las fronteras también
debería ser predominante en un momento
en el que muchos migrantes están
llegando a las puertas de polonia y en
el que rusia amenaza las fronteras de
ucrania de manuel macrón aboga por una
unión europea más autónoma militarmente
ya está prevista una cumbre sobre
defensa para marzo otros temas que
francia debería abordar son la reforma
de los acuerdos de schengen el paquete
climático con el impuesto sobre el
carbono o la reorganización de la
relación con áfrica desde su elección en
2017 el presidente francés no ha dejado
de posar como defensor de europa frente
a los nacionalismos y populismos que se
extienden sin embargo es probable que
estas prioridades se toquen con
divisiones entre los 27 estados miembros
la presidencia francesa también se
considera una ventaja para manuel macro
no posible candidato a la reelección en
las elecciones presidenciales previstas
para el próximo abril pero también una
papeleta que complica su trabajo las
principales reuniones se han organizado
durante los tres primeros meses de la
presidencia francesa y falta un día para
la fecha límite establecida por la unión
europea para que reinó unido- de
resuelva las demandas pendientes la
principal es la que tiene que ver con
los derechos de la pesca en sus aguas
territoriales francia reclama que quedan
cerca de 100 licencias por ser aprobadas
y acusa a londres de actuar de mala fe y
no respetar el acuerdo comercial
resultante el proxy de pescadores
franceses han protagonizado protestas
exigiendo estos permisos
y la organización de estados americanos
aprobó una resolución en la que señala
nicaragua de no respetar sus compromisos
con la carta democrática interamericana
el señalamiento fue respaldado por 25 de
sus 34 estados son miembros activos del
plenario - méxico bolivia argentina y
honduras veamos el informe
nicaragua no respeta sus compromisos con
la democracia esto es lo que concluyeron
25 de los 34 estados que integran la
organización de estados américanos que
firmaron una resolución en la que instan
al presidente daniel ortega a que acepte
una misión para llevar a cabo reformas
electorales en cumplimiento con la carta
interamericana ocho países se
abstuvieron entre los que se encuentran
bolivia mexico argentina y honduras
el consejo permanente de la organización
de estados américanos resuelve hacer un
llamamiento al gobierno de nicaragua
para que permita el retorno inmediato de
los órganos internacionales de derechos
humanos como la comisión interamericana
de derechos humanos y la oficina del
alto comisionado de las naciones unidas
para los derechos humanos la resolución
pide a nicaragua que se permita la
realización de elecciones imparciales
como observación internacional creíble
esto luego de que en los comicios
presidenciales de noviembre en los que
ortega fue reelecto no participó la
oposición ya sea porque sus candidatos
fueron detenidos o se vieron obligados a
exiliarse la oea también pidió al
presidente nicaragüense liberar a todos
los opositores detenidos instar al
gobierno de nicaragua a que con carácter
urgente y como primera medida
libertad a todos los presos políticos
nicaragua pidió su salida de la oea
después de que ésta asegurara que los
comicios no fueron libres ni
transparentes dicha salida es un proceso
que puede demorar hasta dos años en los
cuales las obligaciones de la nación
centroamericana continúan intactos
cambiamos ahora información en india el
ministro de defensa racing anunció una
investigación de alto nivel para así
esclarecer las causas del accidente de
helicóptero del miércoles en el que
falleció el máximo responsable del
ejército además informó que el militar
va a recibir un funeral con todos los
colores en nueva delhi en el siniestro
murieron otras 13 personas y sólo hubo
un sobreviviente
y mientras la lira sigue alcanzando
mínimos históricos el presidente de
iberdown ha pedido a todos los turcos
paciencia y confianza en el modelo
económico de su gobierno es que la
moneda turca ha perdido casi la mitad de
su valor frente al dólar a lo largo de
este año y el banco central ha
intervenido para así evitar que se
desmorone
en file esperan para comprar pan a
precio reducido en el distrito de su
tangas y en estambul un bastión de apoyo
del presidente de reye tayyip erdogán y
su partido acá pero incluso aquí los
residentes están perdiendo la paciencia
y el gobierno debe cambiar porque
durante 20 años ha sido el mismo sistema
la misma política
la situación es realmente mala no soy
solo yo la gente la está pasando muy mal
con panes vendidos apenas a mitad de
precio en una panadería estándar la
producción casi se ha duplicado para
satisfacer la demanda se trata de una
decisión tomada por el alcalde de
estambul como respuesta a la creciente
crisis
estamos produciendo 1.5 millones de
panes y todavía hay colas así que no es
suficiente es una clara señal de pobreza
de la situación actual no es sólo una
crisis económica sino una crisis
política lo veo como un reflejo de la
incapacidad de dirigir el país
mientras la línea continúa cayendo en
picada miles han salido a las calles
pidiendo la dimisión de erdogán pero el
presidente que insta a la población a
confiar en él asegurando que las bajas
tasas de interés hacen bajar el costo de
vida la inflación superó el 21 por
ciento el mes pasado alcanzando un
máximo en tres años
algunos de estos precios altos volverán
a bajar pronto
desgraciadamente una de las razones del
aumento desorbitado de los precios en
nuestro país son los oportunistas
codiciosos
si bien eslogan señala que su objetivo
es la prosperidad y la estabilidad
duradera la prioridad para muchos turcos
por ahora es un cambio inmediato para
aminorar la abrumadora inflación
y la nasa lanzó al espacio un nuevo
satélite para explorar los misterios del
universo la agencia espacial han sido
expert para medir los rayos x- liberados
por los agujeros negros y también las
estrellas de neutrones el lanzamiento se
hizo a bordo de un cohete falcon nine de
space x desde el centro espacial kennedy
en la florida la misión es una
colaboración entre la nasa y la agencia
espacial italiana
y de esta manera llegamos al final de
este informativo en france 24 en famosa
mañana con más información porque por
hoy me despido de ustedes pero continúa
con nosotros aquí en france 24 hay mucha
más información para ver
[Música]